hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen we all look forward to
indulging in pastries baked goods and
candy during the holidays but all that
sugar can really add up and if your plan
is a 30-day January detox stop the hell
right there go watch some of my videos
and meet me back on the flip side no
cleanses here folks just some really
super simple sugar saving swaps to your
favourite holiday treats so you can have
your cake and eat it too
totally go free swap the fruity
Nutcracker with some fruit jam and a
slice of triple cream cheese with a
water cracker some fresh treat and a
thin piece of strongly flavored cheddar
to cut 367 calories and 37 grams of
sugar swap your canned cranberry sauce
for the homemade version substituting
half of the cranberries and sugar for
naturally sweet apples to cut 42
calories and 11 grams of sugar swap your
glass of eggnog for a cup of almond milk
with a pinch of cinnamon to cut 330
calories and 40 grams of sugar swap your
apple pie with ice cream for a baked
apple with oatmeal topping and adult of
fat-free plain Greek yogurt to cut 227
calories and 11 grams of sugar swap your
milk chocolate truffles with a small
square of dark chocolate cut 38 calories
and 4 grams of sugar and swap your iced
sugar cookie for an entre Scottie cuts
60 calories and 8 grams of sugar see the
holidays don't have to mean one
tall insulin spike and another painful
miserable crash later if you were to
make each of these swaps just once you'd
shave off a hundred and twenty grams of
sugar and over a thousand calories from
your holiday meal just imagine what that
would do after a few parties yeah it
means you're probably gonna be feeling a
lot better come the new year thank you
so much for watching guys more great
healthy holiday ideas be sure subscribe
to my channel and I'll see you next time
Abby